if you had an opportunity to coach a
writer before they sort of even got out
of their car and and and then stepped on
a lot
how would you coach them like they have
this big interview coming up you feel
like they're prepared but there's a
couple points you're like their coach in
the ring before they go and see that
receptionist and let them know that
they're here for the meeting what would
you tell them I think the main thing is
the understanding of how to tell and
sell your story and how to use the right
personal stories that show that you are
the perfect writer for the project I
think the current climate in Hollywood
right now is all about why are you the
perfect writer to be telling this story
and I think some mistakes that writers
make is they bring in personal stories
but they're not the right personal
stories to deliver the belief and the
confidence that only they can tell this
story in the way that they can tell it
so I think through right through
coaching writers to recognize what
personal stories link them to the
concept and many writers you know their
personal story doesn't link to the
concept but they may have a personal
story that links to the pursuit of the
lead character or that connects the
matically with what is being said in the
story because of their own personal
experience so it is know and I also
think that many writers go into meetings
fearing being too personal interesting
and I think I'm of the belief you can't
be too personal that's just my belief
there are I know there are consultants
and coaches that believe you can be too
personal I'm of the belief that whatever
is
driving you to tell story I want to know
and understand like I I find that the
greatest thing like one thing I'm gonna
share I have an event in New York and an
event in London coming up and one thing
I I want writers to think about in
developing characters I want to give
them an exercise and that exercise is
listen to any of your favorite songs and
listen to why the words are resonating
with you then get the album of that
artist listen to every word in every
song that that artist has written and
sung and write a character description
going into the wound that is driving
that character because that separates
them from themselves
and it allows them to go into somebody
else's journey and I think whenever you
listen to like say Rihanna or SIA or
Britney Spears or Taylor Swift Katy
Perry
Adele like these are women who
understand how to communicate life
through songs and and they have had
clear moments of despair that have led
to some of the best songs out there so I
think writers have the same journey I
always think writers it's figuring out
how do I take that traumatic life moment
and spin it into gold
so that it connects with my audience in
the way that songs connect with people
how do you get someone out of the trying
to be the perfect student I don't want
to know I don't want to share that I
mean that's different if Rihanna or
Adele they're who they are so I can
respect their story yeah but yeah I'm
not ready to tell that yet but you
really feel like once that person opens
that up and that's that secret out there
that they're really gonna be sort of on
fire but you see them they only want to
present this good side of themselves I
always want the writer to feel safe with
what they're revealing because I think
if you reveal too much before you're
ready then you become extremely
vulnerable and the the vulnerability may
get in your way instead of serving you
in a positive way like say Ferg's I
always think there's a way to tell a
story
say for example I'll give you an example
of somebody who I think went a little
too far with the personal story was
Mackenzie Phillips when she revealed the
incest with her father and for me the
timing in the context of it didn't work
in the way that it could have worked and
so I can take a writer I've had writers
who've gone through incest and I've had
writers who've gone through rape and
I've had writers who who've gone through
eating disorders or anything that that
does contribute to what they have to say
but they don't want to reveal that for
fear that it's too much and I think what
I work with those writers on is
understand a way to reveal without
having to go to any extreme extent
that's going to make you uncomfortable
or you think the room uncomfortable so
so I think there is a way to reveal an
emotional truth that doesn't go too far
and and yet in my opinion you know again
I encourage to like think about the
story first think about what serves the
story it isn't about oh my god this
happened to
it's about because this happened to me
or something similar happened to me and
I identify with this I have something to
say so how do you know if they're ready
I remember something similar someone in
a class reveal something very personal
and I could see that the class kind of
pounced on this person and I felt it was
unfair and I saw them years later and
they weren't doing well and I wanted so
much to like say something to them like
yeah I benefited from your story but it
just wasn't appropriate yes so and and I
can I mean that incident was like 15
years ago and I still see it of Merit
yeah so how do we know that it's too
much too soon because I think we all
want to really get it all out there
so there's no skeleton well I had to
look at like like when I looked at that
mackenzie phillips interview i had to
look at why it made me uncomfortable
like I had to really understand why did
I not think it was serving in the way
that it could because it was her pain
and it was her story to tell and there's
no judgment on that it's just again I
think what is the motivation and
intention behind telling it when you're
telling it so I think that like for the
one that you remember yeah I definitely
think that there is a time in a place in
that and in understanding as I say does
it serve the story or are you just
getting caught up in this life moment
sure you know what I mean we're shocked
no yeah and really understanding does it
serve the story and does it identify you
is the perfect voice to tell this story
and anything less or anything more you
need to pull back from that's like
editing I mean when you look at editing
editing is all about like I cannot tell
you how many times writers will say well
Jen how do I cut back five pages well
alright let's take a look at this scene
like you go so far into this what is
this scene really about and you should
get in and get out who wants what what
getting in the way and how do you get in
and get out and anything else is
exposition and you don't need it
you